Traductor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Este chimpancé tropieza con una
fuente inesperada de ciruelas maduras.
Muchas de ellas se abrieron, atrayéndole
con su embriagador olor afrutado.
Se da un atracón y empieza a
experimentar... efectos extraños.
Este inconsciente simio
ha tropezado con un proceso
que los humanos
eventualmente aprovecharán
para crear cerveza, vino
y otras bebidas alcohólicas.
Los azúcares de frutas muy maduras atraen
microorganismos conocidos como levaduras.
Cuando las levaduras se alimentan
de los azúcares de las frutas
producen un componente llamado etanol,
el tipo de alcohol
en bebidas alcohólicas.
Este proceso es llamado fermentación.
Nadie sabe exactamente
cuándo los humanos
empezamos a crear bebidas alcohólicas.
La primera evidencia conocida
data del 7000 a.C. en China,
donde los residuos de
las vasijas de arcilla
han revelado que la gente
estaba haciendo bebidas alcohólicas
de arroz fermentado, mijo, uvas y miel.
En unos pocos miles de años,
las culturas de todo el mundo
estaban fermentando sus propias bebidas.
Los antiguos mesopotámicos y egipcios
hacían cerveza durante todo el año
de granos de cereal almacenados.
Esta cerveza estaba disponible
para todas las clases sociales,
e incluso los trabajadores
la recibían en sus raciones diarias.
También hicieron vino,
pero debido a que el clima no era
el ideal para cultivar uvas,
era un manjar raro y caro.
En contraste, en Grecia y Roma,
donde las uvas crecían más fácilmente,
el vino estaba tan disponible como
la cerveza en Egipto y Mesopotamia.
Debido a que las levaduras fermentaban
los azúcares de cualquier planta,
los pueblos antiguos hicieron alcohol
de cualquier planta o cultivo
que creciera donde vivían.
En América del Sur, la gente
hizo chicha de granos,
a veces añadiendo hierbas alucinógenas.
En lo que hoy es México, el pulque,
hecho de sabia de cactus
era la bebida favorita,
mientras que los africanos del este,
hicieron cerveza de banana y palma.
Y en el área que hoy es Japón,
la gente hizo sake de arroz.
Casi todas las regiones del mundo
tenían sus propias bebidas fermentadas.
Mientras el consumo de alcohol
se volvió parte del día a día,
algunas autoridades se aferraron
a efectos que consideraban positivos
Los médicos griegos consideraban
que el vino era bueno para la salud,
y los poetas dieron testimonio
de sus cualidades creativas.
Otros estaban más preocupados
por el potencial abuso de alcohol.
Los filósofos griegos
promovieron la moderación.
Los primeros escritores cristianos
y judíos integraron el vino en rituales
pero consideraban una intoxicación
excesiva como un pecado.
Y en Medio Oriente, África y España,
una regla islámica contra orar
mientras se estaba borracho
gradualmente se consolidó
en una prohibición general del alcohol.
Las antiguas bebidas fermentadas
tenían un contenido bajo de alcohol.
Tnía un 13 % de alcohol.
Los subproductos que generaban levaduras
silvestres durante la fermentación
se volvían tóxicos y las mataban.
Cuando las levaduras mueren,
la fermentación se detiene
y el nivel de alcohol se equilibra.
Durante cientos de años,
el contenido de alcohol estuvo limitado,
lo que cambió con la invención
de un proceso llamado destilación.
Escritos árabes del siglo IX describen
la fermentación de líquidos en ebullición
para vaporizar el alcohol en ellos.
El alcohol hierve a una temperatura
más baja que el agua, se vaporiza primero.
Capturar este vapor, enfriarlo,
y lo que quedaba era alcohol líquido
mucho más concentrado que
cualquier bebida fermentada.
Al principio, estos alcoholes fuertes
eran usados con fines médicos.
Luego, el alcohol se convirtió en
un producto comercial importante
porque, a diferencia de la cerveza
y el vino, no se desperdiciaba.
El ron hecho de azúcar cultivado
en colonias europeas en el Caribe
se volvió un básico para los marineros
y fue comerciado con América del Norte.
Los europeos llevaron el brandy
y la ginebra a África
y lo intercambiaron por esclavos,
tierra y bienes
como aceite de palma y caucho.
El alcohol se convirtió en una
forma de dinero en estas regiones.
Durante la época de los descubrimientos,
el alcohol jugó un papel crucial en
los viajes marítimos de larga distancia.
Navegar de Europa al este de Asia
y América podía llevar meses
y mantener el agua fresca para
las tripulaciones era un desafío.
Añadiendo un cubo de brandy
al agua del barril el agua
la mantenía fresca más tiempo,
porque el alcohol es un preservante
que mata los microbios nocivos.
Para el siglo XVII,
el alcohol había pasado de
simplemente animar a los animales
a impulsar el comercio mundial y la
exploración con todas sus consecuencias
Mientras pasaba el tiempo, su papel en
la sociedad humana sería más complicado.